have you ever come in
last
think about that today since our
scriptures focus so strongly on it
i don't mean have you ever done poorly
i don't mean
didn't do as well as i wanted to
or as your mother would say didn't quite
fulfill your potential
i mean last i mean dead last
at yale sometimes one hears so much
weeping and gnashing of teeth when
someone gets an a minus when they
expected an a
last can be hard to fathom around here
we don't actually see it very often
we're sort of like those disciples who
were
they weren't quite humble they were just
embarrassed when jesus confronted them
and said what were you talking about
back there
and they said
well of course which of us
is the greatest
what else do we talk about
look and listen to conversations around
this place and you will hear in the end
it usually boils down to which among us
is the greatest if we were confronted we
would deny it of course because we all
have this wonderful
well-developed sense of false humility
of course not me
i am one of the one thousand who got in
instead of the 26 000 that didn't
but of course i'm just i'm last i'm the
very least of all humanity that's what
people at yale tell you
don't believe it just listen with half
an ear because there's really something
else going on because we don't really
know
what it's like
to be last
for all of yale's diversity efforts the
one group we quite intentionally exclude
is the last
we don't even really acknowledge their
existence
they don't fit in in this place
but still
in every class there's someone
who gets the lowest mark
we wouldn't want to know we wouldn't
even want to see them for fear of
embarrassing them but they are there
in every race
someone brings up the rear
you can see it on any school playground
during pe class i'm sure some of you
remember it
the kids circle running around the
football field
a few running ahead beautiful and bold
the vast majority in the middle huffing
and puffing
and then the stragglers
awkward in gates struggling to breathe
falling further and further behind
if you've ever been there you know the
plea in their head is please don't let
them lap me
but eventually of course the brave and
the beautiful sail by again
no one greets the last at the finish
line
in fact usually everybody's already gone
into the showers
and the coach is yelling at you and
looking at her watch
and you slump sweaty and humiliated
and trudged back to the locker room
no movies get made
about the last
no news stories feature their pictures
or their quotes
their names are not on the roster of
those who star in the play or sing in
the honor choir or make the all-star
team
for most of the world
they are best forgotten
at least to mercifully spare them any
more embarrassment
but what do i do when i hear jesus say
whoever wants to be first must be last
of all and servant of all
it's not us
it is harder for us to follow this
teaching of jesus than for anybody else
because in the end we are the first even
though we deny it we don't want to see
it
it's just me
i suffered once in middle school
someone turned me down at the dance
i've had a really hard life
but we are the first
there's no denying it
but when we hear jesus say whoever wants
to be first must be last of all i want
you to think of that chubby boy or girl
and maybe you may be someone else
running last around that football field
50 yards behind everyone huffing puffing
dying just a little
and not just that boy or girl but the
real last of the last
the mother in the kenyan refugee camp
who was last in line for food
and there's none to be had
the father in a nepali village who is
last in line for rice to plant
and there is none
those who are turned away
when the last runs out
what defines
being last
means you don't have any resources
you don't have any friends
you have no one to ask a favor of when
things are tough
you have no accomplishments or special
talents that anyone recognizes
you are the person who is dictated to by
those in authority
you are the person on the receiving end
of the system
these are the ones jesus would have us
not only see
but be
but
usually the jesus we have doesn't talk
this way because as nathan jennings say
christians have successfully
domesticated jesus
i just want you to think about that term
and take it literally for a moment
we have domesticated jesus
we have caught him
we have broken him
we have trained him
there's nothing wild left in him
we put him through our obedience class
we swatted him on the nose with a
newspaper
we sprayed him with the water bottle
when he breaks our rules
our domesticated jesus never tells us
things we don't want to hear
certainly jesus never says
that the first must be last of all and
servant of all
we want our jesus to be house trained
to not to jump up on the guests
if not to be the best of breed amongst
the divinities
but jesus is bad always bad if you read
the gospel and fails obedience class
just when things were going along so
well with the miracles and the healings
and the huge crowds following him
through the book of mark and everyone so
happy
jesus has to get depressive and hidden
all at once
and tell us that the son of man is to be
betrayed by all humanity
he doesn't name particular people he
says all humanity human hands
will be betrayed and killed
this jesus he's just no fun to have
around
he keeps reminding us that he isn't
gentle jesus meek and mild he's obsessed
with this vision
of a world whereby sacrifice and
innocent suffering the powers of evil in
this world will be overcome and the
world we know will truly be turned
inside out and those at the top will
fall to the bottom and those at the
bottom will rise
the miracles the crowds they're just not
enough for jesus he has to take on the
way our world works
and throw his body
into the gears
the disciples of course should be
weeping by this point
but no
they're busy arguing about which of them
is the best
and in effect what they're arguing about
is when jesus is gone
who's going to be in charge
they're already working on the
succession plan
isn't that what we do
especially when we're afraid or we don't
understand we argue amongst ourselves
about who is best
look at our country right now in the
midst of this election
when we don't understand when we're
afraid what do we do we fight each other
rather than take on the real problems
we argue amongst ourselves about which
church is best which political worldview
evangelical or mainline charismatic or
social justice
i heard on the radio this morning that
when researchers ask americans what
christians are best known for today
it is not
welcoming and serving the least of these
christians are known as narrow moralists
as political animals who want to be the
greatest
who want to tell other people how to
live
so i want to ask you today what would it
look like if christians were known
for being those who loved and served the
weakest and most vulnerable around us
i don't mean that in a theoretical or
statistical sense what would it look
like
for us to be those people that were
known for that
i think first of all we would have to
change our very nature because i think
it's against evolution and it's against
enlightened self-interest it's against
human nature
to be this way
human nature says stick with the
strongest and the most successful people
you can and you will rise with them
it is against our nature
to stick with the weakest and the most
vulnerable
but jesus keeps getting in the way as we
want to find those wonderful beautiful
people that we can be friends with
jesus keeps kissing lepers and embracing
tax collectors he keeps finding god and
all the wrong people in all the wrong
places we want to guide him to the big
donors
to the olympic champions to the wall
street wizards but he picks up a stinky
squalling baby
and plops it down in the circle in their
midst and says whoever welcomes this
baby welcomes me
not the innocent child
the baby that sat behind you on that
airplane for eight hours and never stop
crying
whoever welcomes this baby welcomes me
and whoever welcomes me welcomes god
jesus had to die to open the door to the
possibility that the last and the least
could triumph
why does jesus insist on the last being
first when the whole world knows he's
wrong
dr hammershould once wrote that jesus
didn't hang around with tax collectors
and prostitutes because he was immoral
or because he wanted to win them over or
because he wanted to convert them he
says it was because his humanity was so
rich and deep that it made contact even
in them even in the prostitutes and tax
collectors with that which in human
nature is common to all people
and indestructible
that is what god loves father john shea
writes that the lastness of the last
means the bare basic material of
humanity that is common to all it is
beneath the accumulation of possessions
and also beneath the lack of possessions
in gospel language means to welcome
jesus in every person
jesus loves the last and jesus becomes
the last at his crucifixion and urges us
to become last because it is only when
we are last that all the masks
fall away
and we are revealed for who we really
are in our naked shared humanity
beloved of god
if we have even the illusion of being
first of being greatest among them we
will inevitably deny our common humanity
and find a way to blame the last for
being last
jesus was tempted with being first
in the desert
when satan appeared to him
but he said no
jesus is asking us
to be human
he's saying if you don't touch someone
who the world would consider last maybe
once a week
maybe more often
than you are not touching me
it may be welcoming our church members
who struggle with mental illness it may
be tutoring a child that new haven reads
it may be just identifying that person
in your college that's struggling most
of all
but if we are not touching these people
face to face not as statistics not as
programs or charity
not to make ourselves feel good or check
a box on our resume
if we're not touching someone every week
we are probably not touching jesus
and perhaps jesus is not touching us
because jesus looks at us and sees us as
we are
not as we think we should be
not as others have told us that we
should be
not as we defensively imagine ourselves
to be when we are lonely or hurt or
angry
jesus sees us as we are
jesus lifts off each of our protective
illusions
each of the many ways we imagine that a
job or a relationship or a recognition
will finally make us happy
jesus lifts off our straight a records
our curriculum beta of 200 articles and
six published books
our leadership abilities our track
record of excellence
and finds under it all
you
and me
and in the final totally paradoxical
teaching
that jesus gives
is that if we become if we welcome the
most vulnerable
not as targets of our charity but as
human beings as fully worthy of
self-determination as we are if we love
them and serve them if we become last
with them
then we become first
first
and last
doesn't make any sense
this place is based on being first
pure
and simple
but what jesus says is the only way to
actually
be there
is to renounce it
and to find in the very least of our
neighbors
a common humanity
and then only by discovering that common
humanity in others can we finally find
it in ourselves
and acquire the healing touch that jesus
gives
it's totally countercultural it's wrong
it's evil
don't tell people outside that i said
any of this
i'll get in trouble
this is not what i'm supposed to be
teaching you at this place
but jesus keeps saying it over and over
and over again
the first shall be last the top shall be
the bottom the bottom shall be the top
the only way to enter in to the first
is to become the last the call is not to
some sort of romantic self-flagellation
or pious self-abnegation the call is to
do the work and it's hard work of
welcoming
the last
and the most vulnerable
if we can do it
i don't know what people gonna say about
us
they're gonna say we're nuts
they're gonna say these people don't fit
here
they're gonna say
these people don't understand the way
the world really works
as lynnea tells me
every time she hears an ambulance go by
since she's worked in the hospital
enough
she imagines
who's inside
that's the way we have to think
and the whole world will tell you this
is not the way to be
the whole world will tell you it's about
being the winner
and even christians will tell you it's
about being the winner it's about having
the most successful christian church
with the best people
because that's of course the only way
we're going to attract more people is to
have the most beautiful and the most
successful and the coolest up front oh
and then everyone will come
jesus wants to clean out this place
jesus wants this to be a place where the
most vulnerable can walk in and know
that they are amongst their own
it asks a lot of us
but it's the only way we can be first
with him
amen